Ça a terrifié les gens.
Ils étaient terrifiés par la croissance de la population,
par ce qu'ils ont nommé en 1968 : « la bombe démographique ».
Mais quand on observe la fin du graphique,
on constate un ralentissement de la croissance.
Durant la décennie --
dans les années 70, 80, 90 et 2000
et encore davantage maintenant --
la croissance démographique ralentit.
Notre planète se stabilise.
On sera 9, 10 ou 11 milliards à la fin du siècle.
Dans ces changements, il y a des remous.
Il y a la deuxième guerre mondiale.
Il y a la pandémie de grippe en 1918.
Il y a la grande famine en Chine.
On a tendance à se focaliser sur ces événements-là.
On a tendance à se focaliser sur l'actualité choquante dans les infos.
On ne regarde pas les changements progressifs
et les histoires positives.
On s'inquiète de la population.
On s'inquiète de notre nombre.
On cherche des solutions pour s'isoler des autres.
Voici donc une carte du monde transformée pour agrandir les espaces
où les gens sont les plus éloignés les uns des autres.
Si vous voulez savoir où aller pour vous éloigner des autres,
voici les endroits idéaux.
Chaque année, ces espaces croissent.
Car chaque année, nous quittons nos terres.
Nous migrons vers les villes.
Nous cherchons à nous concentrer.
Les loups sont de retour en Europe
et ils vont vers l'ouest à travers le continent.
Notre monde se transforme.
Nous avons des soucis.
Cette carte montre les endroits où il y a de l'eau sur notre planète.
Nous savons cela maintenant.
Regardez où était localisée Çatalhöyük :
à la jonction des trois continents africain, asiatique et européen.
Il y a un grand nombre de personnes qui vivent là,
dans des régions avec très peu d'eau.
On peut aussi observer les zones où il pleut beaucoup.
On peut raffiner les choses davantage.
Plutôt que de déformer les cartes en fonction de la population,
on peut les déformer en fonction de l'eau,
et les adapter chaque mois,
pour illustrer le volume d'eau
tombé dans chaque petite zone du globe.
Voici les moussons qui se déplacent sur la planète.
Ça donne l'impression que la Terre a un cœur qui bat.
Ceci n'est possible
que depuis que je vis,
visualiser ainsi le monde où nous vivons.
Nous avons suffisamment d'eau.
Cette carte illustre les endroits où nous cultivons notre alimentation.
Voici les zones dont nous dépendons pour le riz, le maïs et le blé.
On s'inquiète souvent de la raréfaction de la nourriture, mais nous savons
que si nous mangions moins de viande et nourrissions moins les animaux,
il y aurait assez à manger pour tous,
tant que nous nous considérons comme un seul groupe d'hommes.
Nous savons aussi
ce que nous faisons affreusement mal.
Vous avez déjà vu cette carte du monde.
Cette carte est produite à l'aide d'images satellites --
rappelez-vous les satellites autour de notre planète
dans la première photo que je vous ai montrée --
cette carte illustre ce à quoi notre planète ressemble la nuit.
En scrutant cette carte,
à laquelle nous sommes habitués,
on pense voir une carte avec des lieux de vie des gens.
Les endroits lumineux sont des endroits où les gens vivent.
Mais rappelez-vous que sur cette image-ci du monde,
nous avons déformé la carte.
Il y a une densité de personnes identique partout.
Nous avons rétréci les zones peu peuplées,
au point de les faire disparaître.
Ainsi, chaque personne est illustrée
selon une importante égale.
Les lumières ne vous montrent plus où les gens se trouvent.
Car il y a des gens partout.
Les lumières sur cette carte,
à Londres, au Caire, à Tokyo,
la côte Est des États-Unis,
ces lumières montrent où les gens vivent,
où les gens qui y vivent jouissent de tant d'énergie
qu'ils peuvent se permettre
de dépenser leur argent
pour allumer des lumières qui illuminent le ciel,
ce qui permet aux satellites de prendre ces images.
Les zones sombres de la carte
sont des zones où les populations n'ont pas accès à autant d'énergie
ou des zones où les populations sont aisées
mais elles ont appris à ne plus illuminer le ciel.
Si je pouvais vous montrer une carte animée dans le temps,
vous observeriez que Tokyo est devenue plus sombre,
car depuis le tsunami de 2011,
le Japon produit 25% d'électricité en moins
maintenant que le pays a arrêté toutes ses centrales nucléaires.
Et ce ne fut pas la fin du monde.
Il y a juste moins de lumière
orientée vers le ciel.
Il y a beaucoup de bonnes nouvelles dans le monde.
La mortalité infantile est en régression
et cette régression est incroyable.
Il y a quelques années,
le nombre d'enfants qui mouraient durant leur première année
a régressé de 5% en un an.
De plus en plus d'enfants vont à l'école,
apprennent à lire et écrire,
sont connectés à Internet
et vont à l'université.
Leur nombre augmente à une vitesse incroyable.
Le plus grand nombre de jeunes gens qui entrent à l'université dans le monde
est composé de femmes, pas d'hommes.
Je peux vous raconter des bonnes nouvelles les unes après les autres
sur ce qui s'améliore sur notre planète.
Hélas, nous nous focalisons
sur les mauvaises nouvelles, immédiates.
Rebecca Solnit a dit ceci d'une façon que je trouve magistrale :
« L'accumulation de changements incrémentiels, imperceptibles
qui peuvent constituer du progrès et qui rendent notre ère
fondamentalement différente du passé, » --
un passé qui était plus stable, --
« dans un contraste obscurci
par la nature non spectaculaire de la transformation progressive,
ponctuée par un tumulte occasionnel. »
Parfois, des choses terribles ont lieu.
On nous montre ces événements effroyables
dans les journaux télévisés, tous les soirs de la semaine.
On ne nous parle pas de la croissance démographique qui ralentit.
On ne nous parle pas du monde de plus en plus connecté.
On ne nous parle pas des pas de géants qui améliorent notre compréhension.
On ne nous parle pas de comment nous faisons nos premiers pas
pour gaspiller et consommer moins.
Voici ma dernière carte.
De cette carte, on a retiré les mers et les océans.
Nous observons 7,4 miliards de personnes
sur une carte proportionnelle aux populations.
Un peu plus d'un milliard en Chine.
On peut observer que la plus grande ville au monde est en Chine.
Mais on ne connaît pas son nom.
On peut observer que l'Inde est au centre de ce monde.
On peut observer que l'Europe est à son extrémité.
Et nous, aujourd'hui, à Exeter,
nous nous trouvons à la frontière la plus éloignée du monde.
Nous sommes sur un petit bout de rocher,
à la limite de l'Europe,
qui comprend moins de 1% de la population mondiale adulte,
et moins de 0,5% de la population mondiale des enfants.
Nous vivons dans un monde en cours de stabilisation et d'urbanisation,
en train de vieillir
et connecté.
Il y a tant de choses susceptibles de nous effrayer.
Mais il n'existe aucune raison de craindre les autres comme nous le faisons
et nous avons besoin de réaliser que nous vivons dans un nouveau monde.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)